think pushes when you you mentioned that
women are told that they're Queens
they're princesses they're special who
do you think pushes that more men or
women I think women because women
influence like my father never called me
a princess like I've never understood
this Prince I think my father called me
meatball because I was a little fat
little baby and my entire life he used
to say maybe you're getting a little
thick let's go to the gym so if we blame
society a princess so in a way if we
blame society if women are the ones that
pass on culture
and women are the ones that are pushing
these lives more than men in a way when
we say Society we're really talking
about women
yeah because we we won it is because
women this is this is why Society is the
way it is because women by women have
the purchasing power in in the world we
buy everything be so corporations media
have learned Pander to women their needs
their feelings because men aren't buying
things more men are more price conscious
not all but most men are not just
spending frivolously and so women we
will just spend on our feelings we we we
spend it's by 90 I think the purchasing
power so media and culture has has set
up things so that women feel good
because they are the ones that are going
to make them rich I mean that goes into
a lot of layers and a lot of levels but
that's the reason why our society is the
way it is and why women are not held
accountable because it's not profitable
I just want to just uh bring it back to
the quick point is that like I don't
know like if I ever get elected into any
house or Congress or anything like that
I there's got to be way to make these
false allegations illegal like like
they're hap like there has to be
something which listen most men have a
friend that has had a friend if not them
that's been falsely accused most men
know of a man who they have a child with
the lovely young lady the child the the
child's mother can utilize some false
accusation to remove that child from
that man's life [__] I got a story on my
channel me being falsely accused of some
[__] we all all of us we all but see we
don't want to talk about that um we want
to talk about uh holding them
accountable all of a sudden we want to
talk about that can we talk about the
DNA testing center I've had it I had two
guys call in they work at DNA testing
centers one guy had to quit one guy
still works there he told me 40 of the
children are not the man's child 40 40
he said 40 somebody it's usually DNA
testing
two scenarios it's where the woman the
person's getting a DNA test because the
woman claims that is their child turns
out it's not the other one is where the
parent is on the death bed and makes
confession or they need a health they
need a liver transplant blood
transfusion and the blood type there's
no way that that can actually be the
father so then they find out that
because of medical reasons you mean
that's not my father then the father
finds out from that way he said it took
such a toll on him that he could no
longer do it because he would be sitting
on the phone counseling the men and the
grown children
who these women falsely Clues we see it
on more we see it on paternity court but
yet we say many to be held accountable
why are these women needing all these
why does Mori exist with you are not the
father the court exists
do you know what would happen if DNA
testing was mandatory if they tested all
women
Calamity my sister told me this should
be standard my sister told me the last
that's why they won't do it I said it
should be a standard thing at the
hospital that's why they won't do it to
me it just makes sense give an epidural
DNA test I'm doing it I'm doing a
documentary on the court system here in
the UK and I um I was interviewing this
guy he he works for it's called fathers
for justice and they help men get
custody of their kids and one thing I
found out is in the UK um you are
actually given a free free Council which
is a lawyer basically if you accuse your
husband of abuse and what the women can
do is they can accuse the guy of abuse
and
um file a restraining order against him
even if he did nothing and if he breaks
that he actually goes to jail and it can
take one to two years to even get the
kid back so he could have a newborn and
not see the kid for two years over a
false allegation and then so he told me
this story of this guy who the mom
accused him of touching the kids
and it destroyed his social life it
destroyed everything he got he got let
go from his job and the man he called
the guy and said I'm going to kill
myself and hung up and he said thank you
for helping me but I can't do this I'm
gonna kill myself and he shot himself in
the head but that's what happened in a
DNA Center that's what a guy quit and so
are are the women held accountable for
causing the men to do that over a false
allegation well no because even if that
turns out that's false oh demand that
still sticks of him forever forever
you're guilty you're guilty until proven
innocent for me same thing as the
essence it's not guilty it's not
innocent until proven guilty it's guilty
until proven innocent you put it out
which is that what Amber Heard and
Johnny Depp that's right look what just
happened with that ESPN don't get me
started
what's his name I don't really watch
sports like that I forget his name but I
know you're talking about
he just and because of a false
allegation because of that he was not
allowed to report at the at the Super
Bowl off of off of that now he's suing
him for like tens of millions of dollars
or something like that it's absolutely
Preposterous Amber Heard should awoke
all women do you know about the Amber
Heard case yeah okay so Amber Heard the
me too all of that to this day she is
still lying through her teeth and we had
to there are sa victims sa counselors
that actually support
um to support Johnny Depp because we
could see it for ourselves there are
women you may not be that way right so a
lot of women we internalize it and we'll
say well my friends and the people I
know but there are so many women who are
like Amber hurt
is a complete the lion and um she took a
[__] on his back no no no nasty young
woman
but not only that but what she did she
she um violated him the things in her
lives are ratchet up and guess what
happened in society just because she
made the accusation
he his life was destroyed it took him
six years in a public trial in order to
get it out there if that trial was not
published if that trial was not public
people would have said oh well you know
the court system is against women and
all that but because we can see it I
knew Johnny was innocent early because I
had saw some stuff with Amber her I knew
she was a narcissist just by the things
she would do but most people were fooled
by her because she was pretty and had a
smile and she just claimed victimhood
but once it came out Johnny Depp his
case was in pivotal for all men and all
women to finally see that yes there are
women and the a large a large number of
women who are lying and the paternity
court Mori if why don't women why don't
you as a woman say correlate say those
women on paternity court and Maury who
the father is not it there's been women
who've been tested 30 men and they still
have not found them we talk about
accountability right because the modern
woman would prefer to lie then take
accountability so with the Amber Heard
Johnny Depp case she preferred to lie
than to be seen because I've always said
that women have a perception right that
they want to keep up they want to be
seen a certain way and so what it is is
that for women image is all of is
everything right and so with Amber ERD
she um she didn't want her image to be
destroyed with the women that go on the
Maury Show and they I'm telling you they
go crazy he should have been doing this
before the DNA test comes out by the way
they're going crazy because what they're
trying to keep an image right the
problem is the reason why MTR I was
talking about okay DNA test should be
mandatory the reason why they won't do
it is because women's image would be
destroyed women want an image in this
society and their image is going to be
destroyed so what they would prefer to
do is lie because there are many people
most people believe that women are quite
innocent believe that they're ones
always they're the ones that are always
a victim right what will happen is their
image will be destroyed and they'll be
seen for who they are and they don't
want it yeah
one of the things that I learned in
doing content in this space is like when
I think about like the reason that
feminism is where it is right now and
the ideals that as what it is is that
it's all a power play it's all it's all
about power
at the end of it at the beginning of it
and at the end of it it's about power
why would you consistently want to be a
victim
to act like you are a victim in a
society and talk about this patriarchy
and talk about your endless oppression
when you're in the freest cleanness
lack of poverty lack of homelessness
lack of lack of and
the most abundant version of that
society that has ever existed in the
history of mankind today what rights do
you not have that I have
but that's what we've convinced them
today as if it actually exists so they
think they could just get away with the
privilege of not being accountable
because of all the structures that are
put into place one thing you guys
mentioned before earlier was about Maori
think about the concept of more this is
why so many women today are incapable of
understanding the word accountability
when they look at the different
structures within our society today the
concept of Mori is she can test six to
ten men but she'll never get booed ever
she gets clapped she can come out up on
stage and never get booed but they'll
boo all six of the guys even if they
were never the father they'll do every
last one of them you as a young boy I'm
sitting here watching this [__] like
damn man ain't [__] man ain't [__] and
that's the [__] that I was looking at
the content men ain't [__] because of
course they had the dudes on the side
saying boo or yay if the woman came out
so it goes deep it goes
that's why there's so many women today
that are just incapable of seeing behind
the trees
they just don't see it they literally
don't say they blind to it but they were
conditioned to be blind to it but
because it makes them a better consumer
so but you know what MJ I'm sorry to
call you right but you know what happens
when they do get found out to be lying
they get consoled oh they run away
oh it's okay so what you what it is is
that there's no accountability me and
MTR no right if a guy does something and
it's wrong and it goes tits up there's
an accountability there right there's a
countability right there women get
consoled they get mother cuddled they
get told that it's okay don't worry
about it so then she does what she goes
and does it again yet because she never
learned the lesson there was no real
consequence
consoled by men and women men and women
exactly there's always a bailout I mean
even the church I mean it it tells a man
to date Born Again virgins
you watch it
they will go automatically the woman is
cheered when he comes out and all these
men are booed she will run off the show
screaming and crying going crazy and
Mori will chastise the man that child
still needs a father she didn't mean it
you know you should still be nice to her
but if the man is but if the man says
that's not my child I'm not gonna they
shame him and it's going to be that what
what do you think about that like all of
this that we've said and we've said a
lot I'm sorry you had a thought earlier
I'm just gonna let you okay really quick
my thought was so what's the solution
right like men talk about we want to be
forward focusing we want to reach a goal
we want to end the solution right and so
back to the proposal earlier it's the
five to ten percent of men right we've
all agreed that men should be leading
right but men have taken a passive seat
to allow women to the the pla the
platform has switched women are being
men we're out here in the streets and
we're doing what we're doing women
we chose to be but we chose to do that
we talked to do so so who whose fault is
it the men or the person making the
choice we made the choice to sleep
though where did that come from because
back in the day when men were bleeding
we're in control of sex they're in
control of relationships okay so where
did that come from it came from a lack
of Father sitting their daughters down
to her Point she brought up a very good
point and I I guarantee you it's just 80
of women had men what do you mean why
but why because there's incentive
structures in place that allow women to
take the father out of the home with no
consequence and women and women
in the last hundred years or absolutely
since the 60s yeah so again women chose
to do that we didn't have to take those
structures up ABS okay so we kind of
were forced to that's another we were
not ma'am no no no no we were not forced
if you weren't gonna get a check if your
husband was in the house and you had to
provide for him and the kids we
absolutely were forced to take foreign
feminism that actually caused this and
we've talked about it earlier I was
talking to Pearl about it about
Cosmopolitan magazine and how they
actually there were it made money to
create in the black family structure
specifically because this is this is
where the problem really lies in in in
the world and in the U.S I will say I
don't know how it is in the UK
um but our family structure they they
purposely destroyed our family structure
um because it made them money
um we can go into even government
welfare government cheese uh there was a
surplus of farmers having cows they
needed to get they needed to make money
government grants and able to somebody
needed to get this this cheese so to get
this milk get the food that they had a
surplus in or it would go rotten and
these Farmers would not make money this
is layered upon layers of layers that
were systematic so saying we did not
have a choice we chose we chose greed we
chose a bag over a man we chose to not
our children we would rather have a
bunch of money than have our children
have a father in the home
no one no no you have to know the
history this is speaking history no
we're not able to work and provide for
their families
they couldn't stay in the house if they
were there that's false then how are
they going to feed the children where
would the children were fat women were
greedy because they were coming from the
government was home black women wanted
to be like white women in the
Cosmopolitan magazine the woman who ran
who started Cosmopolitan magazine the
main editor she's now a Catholic and she
repented from what she did she said we
were teaching women because we wanted
all women to feel that we had a gripe
with white men and so yeah this is his
public knowledge you look it up on
YouTube yes absolutely they wanted black
women to also be part of their movement
in other races because it wasn't enough
the black woman and the black man had to
stay together in the U.S because it was
the only way for us to overcome what
they did was with Cosmo with a lot these
were women that would say you know what
this is a single woman moved to New York
she's sleeping with different men she
has their life she has her own money her
education she's getting these jobs these
women were promoting promiscuity and
living a certain lifestyle when they
were all married they were all lying and
making up these people because it was
supposed to be a fantasy magazine but
women were taken as gospel and real and
so what happened is black women saw the
white woman as as Pinnacle because we're
not going into colorism and all that
that's not what this show is about but
we saw the white woman as what to strive
for as black women we're saying these
white women are free these white women
are independent these white women don't
need no man I don't need mine he's not
doing enough he's not good enough as a
black man when our entire lives how we
came out of everything we did in the U.S
was through the black man and black
women coming together so we allowed
these women in the these corporations
who wanted to make money off of our
backs and they knew that we had a a a a
insecurity about being dark about being
black and we wanted to strive to the
higher societies because white women
were seen as the highest so we think we
want to be like white women get our
education do this do that when those
women were lying even to other white
women they were lying to us as black
women so then the government stepped in
there's a whole documentaries about this
on black history and I mean black
historians will not refute this this is
what we all know as gospel in our
communities so what you're saying right
here is black children when we were
being provided for but it wasn't enough
we wanted to be like white women and we
had greed in our eyes we had we had Envy
in our eyes and we're like I don't need
no black man I can do better I Can Do
Bad All By Myself And so our children
it's a false and everything our children
we're not eating our children were
eating we want it better and yeah
because the idea it's a money
wait so the idea that it's a money thing
and that like women had to take the
government assistant because the men
weren't taking enough money or weren't
making enough money is that what you're
saying so I think it's great that we can
now in our liberated sense that now that
we have the knowledge and understand it
right we can definitely look back vision
is 2020 right and say we will do stuff
different in that time that was the
narrative in the picture is that what
you're saying that is what I'm saying
I'm just okay I just wanna sorry you're
saying the men weren't making enough
money so the women had to take the
government assistance yes so but even
even wait wait wait wait wait oh my God
wait wait sorry so even even then they
had a higher standard of living than
most people did in all of human history
so how is it an excuse when you're
living better than most people did in
all of human history okay so I'm
speaking specifically for the black
families right and so back then when men
were living at home they were not able
to be employable right and so they would
leave why weren't they employable
because they to her she everything she
said is 100 factual right and if we knew
that that was a narrative then of course
we wouldn't have fallen for it right but
because they were trying to divide the
black family they would say men to
provide for your family or things like
that we don't want you to be there
because we know that you're a leader is
in the impact of that so how can we
divide that we're going to give you good
qualifying jobs if you're in the home
but then the woman how can I provide and
how can I do this if he's not in the
home they will take the government if we
all know it's a scam now absolutely but
back in the day that was the reality to
get a good paying job to try to pay for
your family be employable right you
thought you had to not live in the
household so you agree yeah I wasn't
that I wasn't agreeing I couldn't
elaborate on it right and everything she
said was 100 Factor so right but but
listen though if you agree
then why
would they take that solution because
it's almost as if Cosmo created this
fantasy but the black woman attached
themselves to that fantasy that we don't
overthrow the paper today but black men
were never a part of the patriarchy so
what we are trying to be independent
from listen I'm not saying it was right
I can't go back then and speak so then
hold them accountable I agree with that
I've always said we should hold women
accountable this evening right but today
we're still doing the same narrative
right we're still selling city girls and
being out here and being flown out and
women are still buying it yes
whose fault is it for buying it exactly
I would challenge one thing that you
said when you say that if we all agree
that there's 80 percent of women that
are out here running the streets and
then there's a five to ten percent of
men that are taking advantage of that I
reject the idea that the focus should be
on the small percentage of men that are
running the streets when we have an
overabundance of women that are not
acting accordingly I would say let's at
least get that down to five to ten
percent of women are running the streets
five to ten percent of men are running
the streets and then look at them
equally but as long as we have the scale
so tipped that women are allowing this I
say let's clean our own house first
before we point the fingers yeah but
that's why that's that's why I said you
come back to the the one percent because
we understand and we talk about it all
this all the time on the show women make
80 of consumer buying decisions right so
that means you can sell anything to
women who are the people in power that
know this because I'm not in power and I
know this so the people are in power
notice everything is sold to women they
sold in feminism now they sell them city
girls they can sell them I don't know
they can sell them juice tomorrow I
don't know whatever it is women can be
sold stuff so the so like I said the
point of of I guess my conclusion is
that women are not supposed to lead
right they're not supposed men are
supposed to lead the society and men are
supposed to start selling things to men
they won't get as much money but they're
gonna have to start selling things to
men which is why podcasts like this
exist we know that the podcasts like
yours pal is not in the majority of
podcasts and many people don't listen to
it you have a you have a niche because
you because your audience is probably
mostly men men don't buy like women buy
they're not gonna they're not gonna be
on it they're not gonna be the shade
Barrel shade borrower crew or whatever
it's so easy to sell to women we need to
stop selling to women and then
I might get deep but I think we need to
start separating ourselves from certain
types of people yeah go ahead and break
the system right certain types of people
but listen right women are the problem I
100 agree with you Maggie right I wasn't
saying don't focus on that 80 of women
we but it's a balancing fact after you
can't just focus that's extremity right
when you go to one side and you focus
heavy it doesn't it ends up going back
up we don't balance it why do we balance
it when the problem is unbalanced
because unfortunately like why would we
why would we balance it when women are
causing most of the problems because
it's scientific right and just nature
right when you're balancing things out
scientific and it's neat I don't I'm I'm
okay go ahead go ahead the balancing
beam right if you go to one extremity
the other one's gonna go up so just in
approaching we have to be careful to
balance it out this is just how it works
guys let her go ahead that's just how it
works naturally right and honestly how
do we get here so I'm just not
understanding what you're saying with
the beam so how does us like talking
about women hey women we need to we need
to step it up and then the women will
always come in and say well but don't
forget about the men and we're like hey
you know what we can deal with that when
we when we get the women because this is
a way bigger problem than the men why
why is that an issue like how does that
how does that make the problem bigger
I agree we should definitely focus on
the women they need to take
accountability I'm not no I I know but
I'm saying what what about that when we
get hyper focused on that and we solely
focus on that it causes a chain reaction
of the opposite to then happen
that's just it's a chain reaction that's
that's how do we get there we started
focusing on like men having all the
right how does it make a chain reaction
so I'm just I'm just I wanna because
this is very Broad and a lot of times
like as women we say things that are so
broad that they don't like mean anything
okay and so and so if I'm saying hey
women step it up let's do better okay
with this is a problem that's a problem
that's a problem that's a problem that's
a problem we could say okay the men have
this one problem we have five why don't
we tackle one two three four exactly
what how does that make problem over
here bigger so if we have a balancing
beam they have one we have five right
right and so we're trying to take are we
taking five away from here just to get
it to one and one so it can be balanced
I mean maybe are we trying to just take
one and like five away and then he goes
over here right but technically
even if we use the balancing beam right
and like then this would be heavier than
the men's problem the only way to
balance it out is to focus on the
heavier problem first exactly and even
with this analogy like that doesn't I
would argue I think that's feelings we
might be surprised that what we want the
men to change may actually self-correct
if women started acting differently men
are going to holler men are going to try
men are gonna shoot their shot but if we
don't allow someone to have access
without being worthy of it then they'll
either go to someone that will allow it
but if the next girl says you know what
no these are my standards they'll go on
to the next person and if the next girl
says these are my standards men will
change their approach based on the
results that they get but we keep giving
it away so easily there's no incentive
for a man to change so I would argue we
focus on the 80 let's get our house in
order and we may look up and see there's
always going to be that small amount of
people are going to try and you know get
whatever they can for free but I think
men would definitely step them up step
up I think we um we should give them
more credits as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible